yeah you guys got any plans coming up no
no no plans nothing Well no I I have a
I'm doing the cycling thing again yeah
what are you announcing that is by the
time this episode is out are you are you
going to have announced that I think
it'll be done no it'll be like basically
done oh [__] it'll be like I think
because this is like tell us all about
it it's like a month from now right yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah this is like yeah
this is like coming out halfway I think
like near the end of it yeah okay so
I'll do another one of those yeah
because I remember you saying we
finished the RV trip and Connor's like
yeah okay time to start planning my next
event and I was like [__] hell Corner
calm the [__] down stay inside for a bit
play some video games man stop touching
grass yeah I want to go outside more
too much grass man too much grass I want
to go outside man
you're an outdoorsy person now oh no I
just yeah I like going outside and doing
things yeah also because being like
disgusting yeah yeah you know I also
want to uh do more things for charity as
well this year
um and that's one thing I really want to
do and I hopefully have another event in
future that we can do for charity yeah
um yes I just want to do more cool
things like I'm not really interested
about I don't know working from uh
working in my stream set up and doing
that a bunch because you know I still
want to do that but yeah I think my real
passion is just trying to do fun things
and how can I make it engaging yeah I'm
I'm very very excited because by the
time this episode's out I'm gonna be
back in Thailand that wasn't like I
didn't originally plan for that but I
think after you know after our last trip
where we all went to Thailand and we
were only there for a week I just I I
didn't realize how much I missed being
back in like my home country I miss
being in Thailand holy [__] I just I
just wanted to like I just wanted to
because like when we last went back to
Thailand it was like you know busy busy
busy every single day yeah we had
something going on and I was you know
taking care of everyone coming and I was
just like I just wanna I wanna last year
was so [__] busy I just want a month
where I could just chill out and just
maybe do nothing but just enjoy the sun
enjoy the nice weather and just [__]
chill out and I was just like I was
thinking to myself how long has it been
since I last had that I literally cannot
remember since the beginning of trash
taste I think I feel like even just like
this year January and February we've
done more just like these past two
months than like six months last year
yeah it's just like I I keep I keep
waking up and looking at my calendar I'm
like how is it still February it feels
like I've been doing [__] for like six
months yeah it's just so jam-packed but
I mean we do it to ourselves so it's
yeah exactly like being busy I like
being busy as well I also like relaxing
yeah I do I don't know it's weird like I
feel like I enjoy uh okay question when
you like work a lot how much how many
days or or even a day or like how much
time do you need to mentally kind of
like have a reset
like per week or
uh I try and give myself at least one or
two days what's the ratio what's the
ratio of like work to like break that
you can do
um you guys are in sync yeah that was
like the brain so far
I don't know for me it's it's it's weird
right because I can I have these like I
it's either one mindset or the other and
I find it really hard to find a
balancing Middle Ground I don't know if
that makes any sense but there would be
like in time months where I'm like
grinding every day I've got something
going on every day and then like I've
got this like kind of like you know my
mind's just like constantly busy I gotta
do something and then there have been
points where I've had a week off and
I've like it's taken me just a few days
just to get used to having nothing to do
but like once my mindset switches it
also takes effort to get back into like
the grinding mindset as well oh the best
analogy I could uh the best analogy I
can think of is uh remember back in like
University College days where you had
like exam season right yeah and every
single day for like a month you'd be
studying for exams or yeah two months
you'd be studying for exams and you'd be
taking exams you'd just be you know
every day you'd wake up open a textbook
study until you sleep and just piss
yourselves because you're like [__] I'm
gonna fill out this example right but
I've got to get this [__] done and the
only thing you could think of is I'm so
[__] excited for when this is over
I'm gonna do so much I'm gonna do so
[__] much you're you're like every
day you open your book you look at your
steam library and you're like one day
one day that day when this exam over I'm
gonna get just slowly correct your
monitor yeah yeah yeah I'm almost there
yeah I'm almost there and then you get
to the last day you finish the exam
you're like I'm [__] done holy [__] I
feel so good
what do I do now yeah
like that that's that's my that's my
life now where it's like I get I have
this like month where it's entirely
booked out and then I get to the end of
that month uh and which it's slowly
coming up now because I I packed myself
in February I gave myself some time off
to chill out in Thailand
um and then I finished all my work
and then uh I remember I was like I
didn't know what I wanted to do so what
I ended up doing was uh helping my mates
actually so so instead of taking a
holiday I ended up helping Sydney film
uh helping helping Connor with his RV
trip and everything and then I just I
just realized I just ended up filling up
my schedule doing other things instead
of taking a break which is why which is
why I felt like if I take a break of the
country
to actually stop myself yeah like I
can't do anything if I'm in a different
country right that's it is the ultimate
like sorry man I'm busy yeah sorry man
in a different country yeah I don't know
I I I I I recently I'm pretty sure I
said listen dresses right I bought this
really [__] nice coffee machine it
was way too much money but yeah it's
been uh you've reached that age well
you've reached that age where like
you're like my highlight right now is I
bought a new car dude honestly true and
it's made my mornings so much just to
have a lovely ritual where I hit I put
the beans in I grind the beans and I
just it's so nice it's so nice I steamed
the milk myself as well and I'm like
dude this is great and just so like for
me I now like just having if I have like
a little lost like a lion I say lion but
like yeah if I can get like a nice
little relaxing morning where I can kind
of have an hour an hour and a half to
kind of chill out if I have to do
something yeah dude that's like I can
reset like that yeah that for me is
enough because then I get to make this
coffee I get to have a really nice chill
morning yeah and then I can start doing
my stuff yeah I think it says a lot but
you know after everything we've talked
about after like all the exciting things
you've done uh off camera are like the
most passionate I've ever seen Connor
recently it wasn't like being excited
for the RV trip or anything it's talking
about his [__] because coffee machine
like I remember coming to your house and
you're like yo you got to see my coffee
machine I try try a bit of the coffee
come on let me tell you about my
mornings now we've literally gotten to
that point because like I I recently
bought like a new vacuum cleaner like a
couple of days ago I got the latest
Dyson one I've never been that excited
in my last years I'm like oh oh this is
this is not I'll keep trying this ass oh
the green laser that shows you the [__]
on the green laser it also has like
little monos on the back that shows you
the different particles yeah you sucked
up what's that thing yeah so like the
floor looks clean but then this laser
when it points at the Floor shows you
all the [__] yeah it's kind of scary and
it gives you a percentage of like house
dust and like uh other specs and like
what's in the [__] yeah it tells you
what's in the [__] I'm like oh okay I
got a little bit of more house stuff
today all right let's go dude I should
make some overpriced garbage but I will
say they're vacuums very good oh yeah uh
they should they should keep doing that
yeah I mean they are but yeah no I mean
it's great because like I also get to
like I also get to like uh go to like I
have a there's a local coffee store near
me that just just does beans uh and I I
love going there I love beans I love
going there I love talking to the the
elderly couple that runs it and just
saying like man you know I like this
means that you gave me so yeah
I like these ones it's nice it's got my
whole experience then I get excited to
try the new blend that I bought this is
great it's like a it's like a nice like
whole chain of just every part of it
makes me feel like more of an adult more
like I don't know just taking care of
myself just having a nice coffee even
though now I I probably drink an
unhealthy amount of coffee yeah more so
uh it's hard because I have to I have to
pull back a little bit now yeah yeah
because like day one dude it was like
dude I had like nine coffees I couldn't
stop it's just so good it was so good
you had nine coffees let me highball it
was pretty like uh exaggerating sorry I
said drug addicts he was like five it
was still too much I had five hits when
I first tried them it was a good stuff
it was still it was still too much it
was it was a lot but it was great and so
now I'm trying to keep it two a day look
at us man getting inside of a coffee
machines
again you know it's like I've gone to
that point I get it now like I I you
know because when people want you know
that whole thing people do sometimes
this always happens every like every
time on the internet after like a few
months where like there'll be that
article that's like uh no people people
on uh people aren't broke they're just
spending it on the wrong things and it's
like dude sometimes that little thing
makes someone so happy oh yes it is why
would you say that stuff like that yes
people do frivolously spend or sometimes
but sometimes you need those little
things it is like just get you through
the day like sometimes you have a rough
day you have a you have a rough schedule
coming up you've got a packed work week
yeah and just having that maybe having
that milkshake having that McDonald's
something are you buying that one silly
thing you shouldn't have bought just
just got you through that I I had that
recently because I bought a [__]
Groove coaster controller okay okay
so happy yeah Joey will be the guy who's
like I bought a giant trampoline and
we're like Joe you don't have a backyard
it's like I'll make it work I'll find
one I'll find a backyard that I can put
it in Jerry's like Joey's like I bought
one out of ten thousand Pink Floyd
signed out yeah like all right dude I
wish
I [__] wish yeah yeah I ordered this
[__] like uh custom-made like Groove
coaster yeah that like can can connect
to your computer just like simple USB
you can also play it on the switch as
well yeah not on stream yet but I've
been playing it mostly off stream just
because I'm going to bring anything
I'll get to it eventually but just every
morning it's just like a ritual now
where I'm like
I got an hour free boom just right on
the desk
for an hour that's that's my morning
coffee that's that's my shot of caffeine
did you have like did you have like a
purchase because I I feel like we all
had a pretty similar mindset and I'm
pretty sure a lot of people have a
similar mindset where you know in
college you couldn't imagine spending
your money on anything other than things
that will help you survive yeah right
anything like if if if you need if you
need something outside of just you know
video game I don't really count video
games you know because you know everyone
buys video games everyone everyone needs
some entertainment in their lives you
know everyone has I mean it's integral
to my survival yeah yeah yeah okay I
feel like it's integral to my survival
so is like a [__] Netflix subscriber
or whatever right you know or you know
something you know yeah outside of you
know basic you know laptop
um subscriptions or like video games and
you know and food comes after those in
fact
those in University those were more
necessary to me than having a nice meal
okay I could buy a PS4 right now or I
could not eat Top Ramen for the next 10
months yeah yeah PS4 sounding good
remember the first moment you realized I
have disposable income now what what do
I what do I do with disposable income
there's and yeah yeah I think first time
like I think any of us got like our
first paychecks from YouTube right being
like oh oh no for me it wasn't even
YouTube for me it was [__] the BBC oh
yeah yeah just realizing that yeah
just just to say this is this isn't a
YouTuber conversation right now I just I
remember getting that first check no
same with the other jobs as well yeah
well I was unemployed before that yeah
actually no that's not true the the
first time I got a paycheck was when I
was working in the ski fields in nisaco
when I was 16. and I used that would you
buy paycheck I bought a 3DS
hell yeah I was like I was like you know
I could I could like you know maybe go
to a nice restaurant with like some
friends or you know go go out and buy go
to a pub or something you know like yeah
something like that and I was like
I really want to play that new Animal
Crossing though I just don't have the 3D
[__] it I bought a 3DS and I was the
best purchase I ever made yeah I can't
remember what my first I mean outside of
like I've said like games like I said I
don't really count games but I feel like
if I spend more the thing I probably
spend the most of my disposable income
now on now is it's probably like meals
good food I remember a point in my life
where I could eat the same thing every
day yeah and uh be satisfied with it I'm
still kind of at that point but
sometimes I'm like I can I kind of want
a nice meal like every every time I can
University I just bought those uh three
kilogram bags of pasta and I would just
boil it then salt it and eat it
[Music]
and I just wanted a meal because I
wanted the game I didn't want to spend
money and you could eat like like two
months like a month worth of meals just
on my pasta for like two bucks no I it's
insane
I mean just because you can doesn't mean
you should doesn't mean you should drink
a salt it was just pasta and salt like
and occasionally occasionally I would
get like a I would like maybe put
chicken in it but God your arteries must
have been crying yeah for sure for sure
I mean luckily carbs it was like it was
like lunch at the student things it was
like you could get things that were like
wait like very cheap and so I would eat
that a lot and so I saw that as like me
spending money so I was like okay for
lunch a dinner whenever I'm at home I
have to get something that's cheap right
yeah so I would just make that it was
bad I don't know like to me to me the
peak broke uni student food is cup Ramen
instant instant Ram expensive
ah if you get a three kilogram bag of
pasta it lasts way longer and is way
cheaper than probably oh I I would
literally just buy in bulk I would I
would have like I would have like a
little I would have a literal draw that
was just a Ramen draw yeah I did the
little life hacks full of like cup Ramen
and packed Ramen I don't know like to to
me to to me that that's like still the
peak of like broke uni student food I
don't think it was that expensive was it
I don't know maybe it was expensive for
me that's a Ramen I'm only like 30p each
one which is not that much but yeah
obviously a through killer like Costco
yeah uh well there was no Costco near me
okay because I would just I would just
buy like I would have like a monthly
shipment of like Ramen either either
from my mum or just like online I
realize now I'm like I go to university
and you know your parents drive off and
I was like wait where do I buy food from
like is the nearest supermarket was like
20 minutes come on I'm like I don't have
a car when I was back at home food just
spawned in the fridge I was like holy
[__] how do I go to the store to buy
this stuff and I'm just kind of like be
like whenever anyone went to the
supermarket who had a car yeah like hey
can I can I join in yeah yeah and
luckily one of our friends did have it
so I occasionally went with them yeah
all you would have to do but again I
don't know what he should do before like
when we started University at the Tesco
delivery thing like I don't know they're
just in Australia they'd you can uh
order online and they'll deliver it to
your house like from a supermarket yeah
no we definitely didn't know that oh
yeah they'll deliver it to you so I did
Tesco Express or direct whatever it was
like a million times right right and the
other dude would just turn up and he
would deliver all your stuff to you oh
yeah which is great we had to pay like a
small fee it wasn't that much yeah for
you into it but it was great you could
order like 500 frozen pizzas which I
then upgraded to
upgraded yeah well you know you've
really like I think anything's an
upgrade from [__] stupid there was
only so many times I could do it before
I started to really get like struggling
oh my God I want flavor then I realized
that like oven pizzas are like one pound
each for one meal so it's like okay well
I just started eating oven pizza every
day I think I had I think it was stints
where I would eat Oven Pizza like 20 30
times a month how much weight did you
gain from that a lot yeah I bet yeah I
ate a lot of fun you know that's where I
started getting chubby in University I
didn't realize because I just ate
Monster energy drinks and if Ben and
Jerry's was on sale occasionally you
know you're from my cop wants you might
get one you know is that was was that
your biggest not knowing how to adult
moment in University oh for sure when I
realized like [__] it what the [__] do I
eat and I realized I I realized I didn't
know how to feed myself
and I came to the conclusion that I was
fundamentally too lazy and I would never
enjoy cooking yeah uh so what I would do
is that like occasionally we would all
take it in turns cooking things yeah so
I kind of we did that occasionally where
we were taking it that rarely happened I
I wish we had that because I I heard I
had heard of some like households
they're like yeah I click on this day
and everyone feeds everyone and I'm like
if I I think I purposely avoided that
kind of household because I would not
know what to cook I'd be like how do I I
can't feed myself how do I feed several
sentient human beings I'm just imagining
like if it's Connor's turn to like
corgis like bring out the pasta and salt
I got a bang it for you boys trust me
you'll learn to love it yeah yeah
because you know now I see her like a
lot of tick tocks and a you know a lot
of like shorts being like if if you need
to like if you're if it's like 11 p.m
and you don't know what to cook here's
the perfect recipe for you another guy
you're talking yeah yeah you know what
and I look at that I'm like man I wish I
ate this well as I broke Unison totally
fine I I look at that today and I'm like
that's a great [__] idea who am I
doing the same I'm getting all those
spices was super expensive yeah oh yeah
it was it was not like seasonings and
stuff were very expensive yeah flavor
was expensive yeah like getting getting
certain things you'd be like well if you
want um you wanted like I don't know
like uh basil leaves right yeah that's
that's cool and all and that's great and
it would help but like I they they cost
nearly the same amount as an oven pizza
yeah just for that yeah and so it was
kind of like what the [__] am I like
obviously I'm gonna give the oven pizza
and then you realize oh [__] this is why
everyone's unhealthy in this country
because it's like the oven pizza I just
stuck it in for 20 minutes and boom I
have a delicious meal right I still love
Oven Pizza this [__] is fire non-japan
it's terrible and they don't really have
it no the ones I do have terrible but we
had some pretty good ones and I loved it
yeah it's like damn and then I gotta
clean up when I'm cooking I just I just
Chuck it in the oven no tray I just put
it in did you ever attempt to eat
healthy and uh in the University not
even remotely I don't think there's a
single unique student who attends unless
they're rich so buy healthy I don't mean
like you know actually salads or
whatever but at least trying to keep it
balanced a balanced diet I know not
pizza every day no I've had a couscous
stint I ate couscous for like a couscous
for like six months I eat couscous or
couscous and salt yeah no because you
could buy Instant couscous it would be
in a packet right and it would it was
pretty delicious and it was uh
relatively healthy that was that any
different to instant Ramen because it
was way cheaper yeah because it's just a
smaller noodle yeah yeah you could just
pour a bench in a bowl it was like a
nice snack so I would sometimes I would
just pour like four in a bowl yeah yeah
it'd cost like a pound and I would see
that yeah and you pour in a bowl put
boiling water in boom you got instant
couscous it's pretty bomb yeah it was
like uh what's that what's that chef's
name the famous one in the UK uh who did
the Yeah Boy meme oh Ainsley yeah
Ainsley just hit that guy he had his own
couscous brand and I it would always go
on sale so I used to just buy tons of it
a cupboards full of this I'm okay okay
I'm gonna I'm also I'm gonna say this
you know uh a lot of people clown on
Uncle Ben's but I love Uncle Ben I I
think I think Uncle Ben's is the [__]
goat the golden rice okay yeah yeah I'm
just saying I'm just saying as an Asian
sometimes I can't be bothered to cook my
rice okay sometimes I just want to put
that [__] in the microwave okay
sometimes I just that would be I would
make some rice and then I'd realize I'd
you know I didn't finish the rice anyway
I'd left it out for too long I'd be like
[__] do I wait 40 to 50 minutes to like
make another batch of rice or do I just
put in a pack of Uncle sometimes you
just want rice right now yeah exactly
exactly I think if if I had a rice
cooker I even I didn't even know they
existed if I knew they existed and I had
one I would eat way more rice stuff
because I just I cooked like rice the
white way yeah like in a saucepan yeah
and then I would strain it with oh I
would once I cooked the rice I was
taught to strain it with boiling water
oh yeah so I would strain it with
boiling water yeah
and it tastes like [__] I didn't know
why because it's just literally washing
away all the food yeah and I didn't know
that because I I didn't I I hadn't been
tore anything I would send this clip to
Uncle Rogers right now that's the thing
right it's it's it's it's lack of
Education right right we didn't know how
to cook them education we didn't know
how to cook right yeah I was never
taught any other way yeah of course yeah
and so that's you know I I ate it like
that and I sometimes I would make the
you'd make chicken curry because you
could buy those there's so many of them
in the UK because we're obsessed with it
you could easily buy these like one
pound pots of uh chicken curry that you
just literally just uh heat up yeah and
then you you have Curry yeah they were
pretty good all right it wasn't great
but as a uni student it was it was great
if you wanted some Curry yeah for sure